let's talk next where do we want to go
next there's a lot of folks here
what about um
let's go to
is it tealer from
saint uh where is it saint saint louis
is it
taylor t lure
yes it is uh it is from st louis i
bungled up my name but uh
i wanted to ask about
what what is what is up with the
advertisements on your channel with uh
always involving crypto
like what do you mean
most of our advertisers have nothing to
do with crypto
um you always you always do these uh
single video advertisements and
they're always sketchy crypto currency
sort of things
um
i think we did one in the last few weeks
can you give me an example of it being
sketchy crypto
um one of them was uh
one of them was an nft thing which was
the most recent one and the other and
the other i don't exactly remember the
name is the name of but it ended up um
and ended up failing because of numerous
fec
uh warnings against it
okay please don't use push to talk we're
hearing the discord blings come through
um in terms of the nft so are you
talking about a crypto currency or now
you're saying it nft these are two
different things which one did you mean
uh i was meaning the i was meaning all
of them
okay but you so but is this call about
an the the recent nft one or a
cryptocurrency because these are i can i
can't address them
generally if there's a specific
i guess we can i guess i guess you could
address the recent nft advertisement
because
a lot of people
do not
approve of
you advertising these things oh okay
yeah i mean listen we have advertisers
um we make clear when things are
sponsored or it's an advertiser i can't
think of any advertiser that i've not
had people complain about
um when we have
you know a cereal company
people write in saying the cereal is
expensive and not very good and we
really shouldn't be associated with them
when we have a knife company people say
the type of steel the knives are made of
is no good when we
no we never have the perfect advertiser
and so what we're trying to do is we run
an ad program we
have uh advertisers we mark things as
advertisements
we allow people to make decisions about
any advertiser that they want and no
there's no way everybody will be happy
with every advertiser that's for sure
um okay
all right and then the individual hung
up okay
um all right let's go to the next
i figured there would be some kind of
dialogue but i guess not